[Musique]
économie avec la santé financière de
l'agglomération de cquenttin en Yveline
malgré un budget difficile à boucler
avec des recettes en diminution deux
agences de notation ont attribué à la
communauté d'agglomération de C1 un a
plus quelle conséquence Catherine zulato
standards and pours Fitch c'est nom vous
disent forcément quelque chose ce sont
des agences de notation elles sont
connues pour évaluer les pays elles
peuvent également évaluer les
collectivités qui en font la demande
c'est le cas de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline confronté à la difficulté
d'emprunter et à des taux prohibitifs et
pour aller chercher des fonds sur un
autre marché que celui des banques il
fallait être noté pour rassurer les
investisseurs les deux agents sont
accordés un A+ a sorti surtout d'une
perspective de stabilité l'idée c'était
vraiment de diversifier nos sources de
financement et donc d'aller sur le
marché obligataire pour trouver d'autres
sources de financement à moindre coût
l'emprunt bancaire on voit bien comment
il se présente c'est facile on fait un
contrat avec une banque bon là c'est un
peu plus technique ça demande un
arrangeur passer par un arrangeur qui
permettra de de nous faire un contrat en
allant directement chercher de l'argent
sur le marché sans passer par
l'intermédiaire de la banque une note de
a plus c'est certes moins bien que le
triple A bien connu mais qui s'explique
par le niveau d'endettement de
l'agglomération depuis 30 ans si on a un
endettement c'est parce que on a financé
la plupart des équipements des inf
structure de l'agglomération de CTIN en
livvline se faire noter cela un coût
50000 € mais selon la direction
financière rapidement amortissable pour
un emprunt de 100 millions d'euros sur
le marché obligataire l'économie
pourrait être de l'ordre de 100 million
et demi d'euros d'ici la fin de l'année
la communauté d'agglomération a besoin
d'emprunter 30 millions d'euros en
France d'autres grandes collectivités se
sont déjà fait noter dont Paris ou
d'autres collectivités de la région
île-defance chaque année le MF le
Mouvement des Entreprises de France
organise son université cité d'été un
rendez-vous destiné à ces adhérents pour
qu'ils échangent mais qui permet aussi
d'interpeller les pouvoirs publics
l'édition 2012 se déroulait du 29 au 31
août toujours à joui en Josas dans les
Yvelines et pour faire le bilan je
reçois sur ce plateau Bertand de Cré
bonsoir vous êtes le président de
l'antenne des Yveline du meddef le
département des ivelines qui accueille
chaque année ce rendez-vous également
sur ce plateau Johanna sari bonsoir
Johann vous avez passé de bonnes
vacances oui comme vous j'espère
exactement et comme évidemment on
esppère nos téléspectateurs qui vont
dans un instant vous entendre nous
parler de cette université d'été puisque
vous avez pris le pou des entrepreneurs
sur le terrain vous êtes allé voir
comment il réagissaient aux différentes
annonces parce qu'il faut dire que
l'université du mdeef c'est un endroit
très couru en tout cas par les
politiques on a recensé 11 ministres en
3 jours est-ce que ce sont des visites
qui servent à quelque chose en tout cas
vous comment vous l'avez ressenti alors
oui oui c'est vous savez le s'il y a
vraiment une chose on souffre c'est le
manque de communication c'est de ne pas
se parler et si on veut que les choses
changent il faut il faut arriver à
communiquer
donc on a reçu le premier ministre et on
a conclu avec avec Arna
mondbourg merci à ces ministre déplé
venu nous voir mais il y a pas eu
d'annonce très formellement été
concrétiséorsuniversité d'té si si si
j'ai j'ai commencé en vous disant merci
cétait avant de mettre un bémol un petit
bémol maintenant il est clair que
Jean-Marc HUD nous a fait un discours de
politique
générale très bien don Act il nous a dit
qu'on avait besoin des entrepreneurs don
acte mais il n'a rien annoncé de
concret quand Montebourg nous dit qu'il
préfère les entrepreneur au spéculateurs
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord avec
lui maintenant quelle mesure messieurs
les ministres parce que le mal des
entreprises en France on le connaît
c'est le le coût de l'emploi c'est la
fiscalité excessive et et je dirais Mme
la fiscalité incertaine parce que les
mesures sont annoncées sont prises
quelle visibilité avant- nous nous avons
besoin de de de stabilité de savoir où
on va et dans ce sens nos ministres NT
pas vraiment éclairé je même vous donner
quelques extraits des déclarations qui
ont été faites par les ministres pierre
moscovicii par exemple le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances la banque
publique d'investissement verra le jour
dans quelques semaines elle doit aider
les PME et les PMI à réaliser leur
projets en région est-ce que c'est
intéressant mais c'est intéressant c'est
comment voà c'est voilà B quand on me
dit ça c'est bien mais j'attends autre
déclaration celle de Pierre Belon le
fondateur de l'entreprise Sodexo
entreprise de restauration l'un des
leaders mondials dans ce domaine qui
était plutôt remonté lors de ces
universités d'été malgré tout le respect
que nous avons pour les hommes
politiques c'est Pierre Belon donc qui
le dit on en a rbol de nous entendre
dire ce que nous devons faire on en a
rbol des leçons de morale et bien alors
j'étais dans laère et vous avez applaudi
à cette applaudit et et même je vais
vous amuser mais dans les petites notes
sont devant moi j'ai cette phrase de
Pierre Bellon je vous l'aurais sorti si
vous l'aviez pas donné donc non non elle
a marqué bien évidemment il faut vous
savez il faut couper le coup au à
l'idéologisme de lutte des classes qui
veut opposer deschs d'entreprise des
patrons à des
employés aujourd'hui il y a des choses
très simples pas d'entrepreneurs pas
entreprise pas d'entreprise pas d'emploi
et l'entreprise n'a jamais eu comme but
de créer des emplois l'entreprise c'est
quand elle se développe c'est quand elle
croit qu'elle crée des emplois donc
laissez-nous faire notre boulot et quand
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le leader du Front de
Gauche déclare lui n'était pas présent
au MDF mais lorsqu'il déclare on ne
discute pas avec le MDF ça vous agace je
pas que ça m'agace trouve dépassé
trouvez ça com c'est voilà un idéologue
des classes qui à mon avis est
totalement dépassé c'est un dinosaure
parce que moi je crois tout à fait
l'inverse c'est en discutant c'est en
mettant les partis en présence qu'on
arrivera à trouver des solutions et
c'est surtout pas en faisant la chaise
vide ou ou l'affrontement qu'on trouvera
quelque chose d' on va voir comment les
chefs d'entreprise justement on réagit
Joan je le disais tout à l'heure vous
étiez présente sur place vous avez suivi
un petit peu les différents échanges
est-ce que les chefs d'entreprisees
justement ont été plutôt sceptiques déçu
après les différentes visites de
ministre et les différentes déclarations
et bien globalement les patrons
attendaient plus de concret et plus de
vigueur je vous propose tout de suite
d'écouter Mathieu Gill et Sébastien
vercus deux chefs d'entreprise basé sur
SaintQuentin en
evveline j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses
très intéressantes j'aurais bien aimé
avoir des dates un peu plus fixes euh
sur des prises de décision nous sommes
des chef d'entreprise on ahabitude de
prendre des
décisions sur lequel on s'engage auprès
de nos salariés sur des dates sur des
prises d'action il a manqué à mon avis
un petit peu ses ses engagements les
politiques doivent faire de la politique
et qui laissent aux entrepreneurs le
soin d'entreprendre voilà j'ai trouvé le
discours de Monsieur héros somm tout
intéressant mais mais mais un petit peu
loin en fait de ce qui sont nos
préoccupations
quotidienne on va dire c'est à la fois
des des des des difficultés commerciales
de trouver du business et c'est là où il
y a parfois un petit peu de de de
différence avec les discours du premier
ministre nous quand on cherche à
recruter on a énormément de mal
finalement à recruter aujourd'hui il y a
des profils qu'il est quasiment
impossible de recruter certes le taux de
chômage a atteint les 3 millions mais
concrètement pour Mathieu Gill qu'on
vient d'entendre le problème est lié à
la formation la proposition du
gouvernement au sujet des contrats aidés
et des emplois d'avenir ne concerne pas
son entreprise qui recherche du
personnel qualifié et expérimenté autre
point la refiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui en théorie doit
permettre de nouvelles embauches les
chefs d'entreprise nous expliquent qu'en
pratique aucun poste ne sera créé les
conséquences sont sont très concrètes
sont très négatives et sont immédiates
puisque nous avons pris le parti à
l'époque où cette loi a été votée
effectivement de faire profiter la des
fiscalisation des heures supplémentaires
à un certain nombre de salariés parce
qu'on avait la possibilité de le faire
des gens qui sont sur des chantiers des
gens qui vont installer du matériel des
gens qui sont à l'extérieur quand on
fait faire des heures supplémentaires à
un salarié Vous faites faire je sais pas
je vais vous dire 4 5 6 heures par
semaine supplément supplémentair pardon
un salarié en une semaine c'est pas
parce que je ne vais plus lui faire
faire ses heures supplémentaire que je
vais embucher quelqu'un donc de toute
façon moi je n'embaucherai pas une
personne supplémentaire je n'ai pas les
moyens de le faire et pour lui c'est du
pouvoir d'achat en moins instantanément
si toutefois l'activité redémarre
fortement là oui bien évidemment on aura
la possibilité peut-être d'embcher
et de ne pas faire de supplémentairire
mais en l'état actuel des choses c'est
une très mauvaise décision et qui encore
une fois pénalise principalement mes
salariés moins mon entreprise on va dire
bah je suis un petit peu déçu parce que
nous nous faisions appel aux heures
supplémentaires pour une raison simple
c'est qu'en tant que société de
croissance nous avionsah besoin dans des
pics de d'activités de faire des des des
heures supplémentaires et cette
refiscalisation est un problème à la
fois pour nos salariés puis à la fois
pour le pour les les résultats de
l'entreprise qui nous permet d'être qui
nous permetta d'être investi réinvesti
après donc je suis plutôt contre cette
refiscalisation mertrand de Cré votre
position face écoutez je ne peux qu'être
d'accord avec ce qu'on exprimé ces deux
chefs d'entreprise que par ailleurs je
connais bien puisqu'ils font partie de
de mon mouvement euh la défiscalisation
des heures
supplémentaires c'est comme si on
pensait que l'emploi était un gâteau
partageable on ne coupe pas les partions
pour les partager enre nous je vous l'ai
dit en coulisse notre pays France est un
pays de PME alors on ne parle que du Cap
40 généralement aux informations mais
mais nous sommes un pays où les PME sont
majoritaires une entreprise qui a 4 5 ou
si salariés qui avait trouvé par ce
biais la façon d'ailleurs de mieux
rémunérer ces ces salariés d'avoir une
économie qui était une économie pour
tout le monde pour l'entreprise et une
une amélioration du pouvoir d'achat du
salarié contre des heures de travail
demain quand on a trois salariés qui
font comme vous le dit Mathieu Gill qui
font 6h ça crée pas un emploi ça ça crée
pas d'emploi par contre si on baisse les
charges si on ils vous l'ont dit les
entrepreneurs ils viennent de vous le
dire si leur entreprise croit si elle se
développe elle embauchera c'est là qu'il
faut appuyer c'est le développement de
l'entreprise mais ces mesures je dis
encore c'est l'idéologie ça on prend
l'emploi on le portionne et on va faire
c'est comme pour les 35 he donc je suis
absolument contre cette mesure enfin les
patrons des PME se plaignent aussi d'un
problème de gestion de l'administrative
alors ils se sentent dépassé par les
lois les mesures qui évoluent sans cesse
ils évoquent notamment des aides alloué
pour de court duré
non renouvelé ou remplacé bref un vrai
cassette pour ces petites et moyennes
entreprises merci Joan pour ces
précisions Beron de CR il nous reste
très peu temps j'ai encore deux
questions à vous poser alors je vais
vous demander d'être le plus concis
possible perspective économique pour
cette rentrée l'année va être difficile
l'année 2013 s'annonce difficile
récession pas récession alors écoutez
haose du chômage comment vous percevez
les choses dans le département
aujourd'hui nos indicateurs on a une
croissance qui est à tonne on a 3
million de chômeurs on passer la barre
on a une consommation qui amorce un
repli tous les indicateurs nous le
disent on a un frein sur
l'investissement et on a des
exportations qui s'essoufflent c'est pas
très réjouissant tout cela en plus je
dirais qu'on a une crise qui se qui se
nourrit un peu un peu d'elle- même
qu'elle est plus profonde en 2008 parce
que on n voit pas la sortie mais ça
c'est un éléement psychologique écoutez
moi j'aurais je dirais que la la la la
situation clairement n'est pas bonne
mais j'aurais envie de faire confiance
entrepreneur à ces hommes qui sont des
moteurs qui sont capables d'entreprendre
même par temps difficile les de ç que
vous avez vu sur le plateau ben il y a
un entrepreneur qui a créé son
entreprise j'ai moim-même créé la mienne
en 2005 euh on en trouve et tant mieux
c'est avec eux qu'on réussira une toute
dernière question vous allez me dire oui
ou non 1er juillet 2013 fin de la
présidence de Laurence Pariso
normalement ça doit s'arrêter au bout de
deux mandats tout à fait vous êtes
favorable à une révision des textes pour
qu'elle fasse un 3oè mandat je dirais
que là c'est pas c'est pas un domaine de
ma compétence vous souhaitez avoir une
autre un autre une autre représentante
ou aujourd'hui nous avons des règles
euh si demain elles ont on peut les
modifier sous certaines conditions si
l'ensemble des adhérents et là là ça il
faut de la démocratie c'est la voiemoc
s'exprimera si la question est-ce que
vous êtes satisfait des deux mandats en
tant que président de Laurence parizo
jusqu'à présent trouve que Laurence
parizo a bien porté la voie de
l'entreprise s'est battu pour nos dans
nos intérêts oui alors on verra si
c'était sa dernière universitéétait du
meddeef on verra ça si elle été
reconduite ou pas après changement de
statut merci d'être venu Bertrand de sur
ce plateau pour commenter un petit peu
ces universités d'été du maisdf
n'oubliez pas puisque cette édition du
78 est maintenant terminée que l'actu le
tout image de la rédaction est à
retrouver à 20h30 et à 22h il sera bien
sûr question de la venue de François
Hollande le chef de l'État du côté de
Trapp pour la près rentrée des
enseignants et puis je vous rappelle
également que Henry Guenot député de la
3e circonscription des ivelines et
maintenant candidat à la présidence de
l'UMP l'ancienne plume de Nicolas
Sarkozi qui avait fait une arrivée
remarquée dans le département il y a
quelques mois c'est donc la fin de ce 78
rediffusion 19h 22h30 et minuit
réalisation signé ce soir Xavier Jalin
prochain direct mardi à 18h il sera
question de la rentrée bien sûr en
compagnie du recteur de l'académie de
Versailles également invités sur ce
plateau les directeurs des salles de
cinéma de quartier de trappe et
d'élencour qui font leur révolution
leurs cinémas font po neuve plus de
détails demain et puis le site Internet
de TVfil a également fait po neuve
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez y
retrouver toutes nos émissions puisque
c'est aujourd'hui officielle c'est la
rentrée de TVfil excellente soirée bonne
rentrée
[Musique]